to impress my fling I had a threesome
experience with him and his friend I
absolutely hated it and regret
continuing it for seven hours once when
I was in tenth grade I dated a girl
because I felt bad for her but I was not
attracted to her at all I realized that
I was leading her on so broke off the
relationship she has major trust issues
and hasn't dated anyone since then it's
been nine years I was out with my kids
in the mall and bumped into an ex flame
being a single mother I flirted with him
but when he asked me if the kids are
mine I lied to him and said they were my
sisters my kids heard that and asked me
if I won't be taking them back home with
me it broke my heart I think it's hard
for me to empathize with that just
because like I'm so excited for the day
that I have kids I do understand not
wanting to be judged and wanting to be
seen a certain way by someone when I was
11 I got into a relationship with the
guy I met online who claimed he was 16 I
was planning on going to meet him but my
parents stopped me I found out later
that he let his next victim to commit
suicide well this kind of hits a little
close to home for me meeting people
online kind of helped my self-esteem
because it made me feel like oh this
person doesn't even know me and they
want to talk to me and it makes you feel
like you're pretty and you're worthy you
don't actually need that validation it's
kind of just got to come from yourself
not some random man on the Internet
I am a married woman but I am still in
love with my first boyfriend I don't
think I love anyone like I loved him
sometimes I imagine him when I'm making
love to my husband that is interesting
and also I think it is it is pretty sad
I'm about to get married
and from time to time I do think about
like past relationships and I I don't
necessarily think of them in the light
of like I wish I was still in them just
more on a reflective side of things but
I think you should probably question why
you're in the relationship you're in
right and like if you still really love
like your husband it might be something
that you guys can actually work through
together even if it's hard
my ex-husband told me that he was abused
by his father when he was a teenager I
saw abusive tendencies in him as well
but I stayed with him for six years
because I was sure I could change him
but after having our son he finally did
it he gave me a black eye my biggest
regret was ignoring all the red flags
because not having my ex Ron has brought
me so much relief
yeah oh yeah it's kind of this like hope
that you're clinging on to that like
we'll make a difference right you know
hoping that someone would change and a
lot of times it's so heartbreaking
because the reality is sometimes people
don't change and I also would urge this
person to not be so hard on themselves
because you know where they were coming
from was such a place of love and
compassion it just turned out that you
know this person maybe wasn't ready for
it
I had an abusive ex-boyfriend and
adopted three cats with him in an
attempt to improve our relationship one
weekend after staying with my mother I
returned home to find that he had
purposely killed our three cats to
punish me for having gone for the entire
weekend I called the police and have a
restraining order for him but I was with
him for so long and it terrifies me oh
my gosh how do you help somebody in that
situation how do what can you tell them
to make them feel better you know you
kind of get yourself out and you leave
and you do what's best for you and you
know to ever this is from I'm proud of
them when my husband's parents divorced
last year his dad stopped talking in I
told my husband that it was his dad's
job to reach out first a few weeks later
his dad committed suicide I regret ever
saying anything maybe if I stayed quiet
my partner would have spoke to his
father and things could have been
different our time with other people is
not a given thing it closes saying maybe
if I stayed quiet my partner would have
spoke to the father but it's also
possible that person might have taken
the same approach and waited for the
father to contact so I advise people
from not to be overly critical with
themselves at times even though this is
a grave tragic situation but um I'm a 19
year old woman who has never fallen in
love before and I had never really
identified to any particular sexuality
when my best friend told me that she was
in love with me it made me feel amazing
I wanted to be honest so I told her that
I wasn't sure she said she would wait
for me and after six months I said yes
but one week later I broke up with her
because I realized I wasn't gay I felt
so guilty confused and ashamed but the
experience made me better understand who
I was and more accepting of my mistakes
yeah I know what it feels like to both
love someone who doesn't love you back
and also to be on the receiving end of
someone's feelings and not be able to
reciprocate them and I think both of
them can actually feel really terrible
sometimes the easy decision is to say
yes okay let's stay but if it's not
right and if you feel that in your core
then it's more harmful to us actually so
sometimes the most loving thing that we
can do to someone else is actually be
honest with them I let my emotionally
abusive boyfriend influence my college
choice I chose a small local college
over an Ivy League because he was afraid
that I'd become more pretentious in a
bigger College [ __ ] that guy damn it
sounds like they were going for
something and the boyfriend was afraid
that you know she would become a little
too
good for him and if that's the case and
people want to prevent you from being
your best good self I say it's ok to
outgrow people like I'm very sorry that
you know this abusive boyfriend was that
manipulative because that should never
happen to anybody but on the other end
of it I think this probably can be a
huge opportunity for this person to
realize how much power they have and
like you know be able to choose for
themselves I hope that there's a
discovery of that power or there has
been for this person
[Music]
you